oh a man called me the n-word
i'll say that and it was a black man
uh black man called me the n-word and
i just i just said hey man you know it's
our time brother
that's what i told him i said it's our
time to shine baby
you know blm daddy we can't be putting
each other down
um so
you know just interesting how do you how
do you deal with kind of inverse racism
a little bit
have you ever had to deal with anything
like this riley
um some uh sometimes a little with um
racism with being asian and all um as a
child i mean now
never i mean even if i do i kind of
laugh it off as a joke because i mean i
honestly couldn't care less what people
think
yeah um about that like i'm not i'm not
too sensitive about racism racism
to asians yeah um but
and asians handle things differently man
right you guys are really kind of like
you guys kind of bob and weave with the
racism i feel like
right you know and you know you guys you
know you look at asians there's and
there's also
all different what i don't like is get
specific with the racism
these asians you know i've said it i've
definitely said it
i'll be honest with you oh yeah everyone
has yeah i mean i'm sure you probably
said
you know if people are behaving a
certain way i mean i stereotype all the
time
and i like it sometimes it doesn't mean
my heart is bad
right there's such a difference between
somebody who's out there sharpening a
sword
writing you know you know some
writing a name on it like writing a
black man's name or a
white man's name or an asian man's name
or something on it you know
this you know this sword is for you know
ladarius or something you know it's like
that's crazy but if you're just like oh
man dude these asian people are driving
me nuts if say if you're stuck somewhere
at a
festival or something like an asian
festival
that's not is that racism if everybody's
asian at the festival
not really yeah yeah and plus dude you
gotta look at
i believe that we all are gonna i
believe in beige power
that's what i say i believe we're all
hurtling towards one
color eventually tone you and i are
probably the same skin tone
yeah about yeah get in there closer
i mean we're almost the same damn skin
tone man right
you know it's also yeah i don't know
what i'm talking about but
but yeah the guy called me the n-word i
don't know what to do you know and
honestly part of me
i was pretty excited i'll be honest with
you
you know i quit using the n-word
probably about four years ago when
everybody else did
fully i mean i would never actively you
know
but people would you know if i saw it in
a
sometimes people would do met you know
like you'd be playing that game of
when you draw something out of a hat and
you try to act out the movie
you know what that game is riley you've
ever played that in your town
um yeah charades yeah yeah definitely
trades and uh
are you good at charades no not at all
oh wow
i wish i was and
what i would see was uh people would
write it in there
right in a racial slur or something and
so you'd pick it out and you start
acting it out and you're like oh [ __ ]
this isn't even a movie you know this is
racism
right so you know you'd see that old
trick but
anyway uh but yeah i should know how to
react
you know i didn't know how to react to
that and so i
just i figured one day we're all gonna
be the same thing
so i try to channel that energy from the
future
and say hey man
you know just accept the name just it's
our time baby
you know we're out here brother that's
what i said
and i tried to handle it as good as i
could you know because there's no
there's no correct way to handle that
kind of thing good evening good
afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one ah